こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
今日はちょっとね
一回落ち着いて
美容の動画を撮ろうと思います
美しい皆さん
キレイになりたい男子
こんにちは
体のムダ毛どうしてますか？
まぁ女の子は気になりますよ
男の子もね、ひょっとしたら
毛を気にしてる人もいるかもしれない
僕もね、毛がもじゃもじゃしてるの嫌なんですよね
で、一回僕の毛を見ますと
ま。やっぱね。ちょっと生えてるんスよね
毛が生えてる訳ですよ僕の体にも
すね毛もね、生えてますちゃんと
これからドンドン暖かくなってきて
肌の露出をすることが多くなる
非常にヤバい(; ･`д･´)
これは何を意味するのかというと
そう
ムダ毛処理をしなきゃいけない
僕が独自に開発した
全身脱毛の仕方をみなさんにご紹介しようと思います
これをすれば毛深いそこのキミも
もうムダ毛なんてね
(*ﾉωﾉ)⇒('Д')
ですよ？
所沢にピント合ってんじゃん
というワケで今回は極秘です
まだ誰にも言ってないからね
今日は特別にみんなに
全身脱毛の仕方を
教えてあげる
では、いこう
用意するものはコチラ
一瞬で毛根脱毛スルツベ長持ちというわけで
ムダ毛を除毛するシートがありやす
まぁ普通に体に貼って剥がせば
毛が取れるってものなんですけども
こういうの！
ペタペタペタペタやってても時間が掛ってしまうんすよ
ピ～ヤ(｀・ω・´)
あ。やめとこ今のは
ペタペタペタペタやってても時間がかかってしまうんスよ
そこで！わたしは考えた
そう！これ一つに40回分入ってます
今回５個用意したんで200回分あります
うわなんか...
え。これガチじゃん(´・ω・｀)
なにこれ('Д')
これ待って...結構こわいな
あーなるほど
いいだろう
受けて立とう！
コレなんか色おかしくね？
こんなに個体差があるか
なんか個体差があるんだけど
え？
これなんかおかしくね？
まいっか
で、これをこのままとりあえず
体の全身に貼るんですけども
これ一枚ずつ貼って取っても時間がもったいないので
強力な洗濯バサミを準備しました
この洗濯バサミを
シートにつけて
それに紐を通して
紐の先を固定できる場所にグルグルって巻いて
それを僕が
フンッって引っ張れば
体中の脱毛シートが
ブンッ
って取れるはずです
そうすれば僕の体の毛は
全部なくなります
もう一発でしょ？
一瞬で全部脱毛できますよ
まずは一斉に引っ張るための紐を準備します
(^^♪
イテッ！
痛っ！！あ、あ、痛い！
痛い...痛い...
はい。というわけで
無事全部できました～
約30分かかりましたね
こりゃ多分普通にやった方が早...
コチラのドアノブ
ここが固定部分になります
この固定部分に
ハンガーを全部取り付けていきましょう
よし！できました
全部装着完了です
ここまでくるのに約一時間
普通にやったほうが全然早...
はい！というわけで
ここから僕の体に
実際にこれを貼っていきます
どんな感じなんだろう
ガムテープより絶対強いんですよ
普通にこわいんだけど
うわ～マジか
めっちゃ...めっちゃ粘着力が
うわぁ
毛並みを揃えて
ペタッと
ヤバいヤバいこれはヤバい
これ絶対ヤバいやつだ
いや今回ヤバいぞこれ
ワンチャン死にますよ
産毛みたいなやつも全部抜きましょう
どうせなんで
うわッ
はい！できました
ひとまず貼れそうなところ体中に貼ったので
これでいまから
強力洗濯バサミを紙につけていきます
うわこれ俺大丈夫なのかな
全身にでしょ？
キャッチ！キャッチ！キャッチ！
キャッチ！キャッチ！ＯＫ！
俺キャッチオッケー
いッ！！いだッ！！
いだッ！皮膚ッ！！
強力な洗濯バサミだから多分いってるはずだよ
これでキレイに脱毛できればいんですけどね
いいんじゃない？
ＯＫ！完成しました！
いっでぇ！！
いてッ！待って！！
ヤバい！ヤバい！
今衝撃の痛さを感じた
これが！俺の発明した
全身脱毛器
一瞬で体の毛を全て脱毛できます
効率は悪いよ
効率は悪いけどさぁ
俺はこの一瞬にッ！！
全てを賭けたいッ！！！
いきます！！
いやまっ、ちょっ待って
あ、ヤバいマジヤバい
マジヤバい
まぁいいでしょう
や、やろう
やろうやろう
やる...やるよ？
やるやるやる...
全身の毛よ！
サラバ！！
スリー！
トゥー！
ワン！
ぅあ゛あああああッ！！いだッ！！
ん？
う～
あ！いっでぇッ！
ぬぁあ！！
ああ゛あッ！
ぅああ！！
はああッ！！
ぅうあ
はぁん
いでで
っああ！！
いったッ！
んんん
ぬっわ
はぁっ！！
いっでッ！！
痛い...痛い...痛い...痛い...痛い...('Д')('Д')('Д')('Д')('Д')
大失敗☆